hello this is presh talwalkar this is
the final video in the series on how to
solve the rubik's cube where we solve
the final layer
so once you're done with this you'll
have solved the cube
all right we have two layers of the cube
solved
and now the task is to solve the final
layer
the first step in this process is to
create a yellow cross
in the cube we're looking at we don't
have any of the pieces of the yellow
cross complete your cube may have two
pieces either adjacent or across from
each other
so i'll get to those we're only going to
need to know one sequence of moves
so we go f
r
u
r prime
u prime
f prime
when you do that when you have none of
the yellow cross
you'll end up getting two pizza pieces
in the yellow cross
so here we have two adjacent pieces
and we want to orient them so that
they're going to be the left and back
pieces from whatever face we're looking
at so it's very important you can orient
this in a couple of different ways
we're going to look at the face that
gives those two pieces to be the left
and back sides of the yellow cross
then we go ahead and do f r u
r prime
u prime
and f prime so it's the same sequence of
moves
and now
those two adjacent pieces will be two
opposite pieces
and we're gonna look at the same face
and do the move again
f
r
u
r prime
u prime
and f prime
and that'll bring us to the yellow cross
so it doesn't matter whether you start
out with none of the yellow cross two
adjacent pieces or two opposite pieces
this is how you solve the yellow cross
at this point you've solved two layers
of the cube you've solved the white
layer
you solve the middle layer and now
you have the yellow cross
so now what we're going to do is
position the pieces in the yellow cross
so that the edges are matching the
centers
so
turn the cube around and inspect it
at first there are no edges that are
matching so let's rotate it around until
we have one that is matching
when you have one that's matching
it's either going to be two opposite
pieces here we have green and blue that
are matching or they're going to be two
adjacent pieces you may also have all
four of them
solved in which case you're already done
but let's start out with the worst case
where they're two opposite
sides that are matching
so look at one of the sides which is
opposite and then do r
u
r prime
u
r
u
u
and r prime
and what this will do is this will bring
us to the case where we have two
adjacent pieces that are matching
and final
now in this case we want to transpose
the two that are not matching
so let's look at the two pieces which
are matching and put them
on the right side and the back side so
that's how you want to orient it and
look at a face so that the adjacent ones
which are matching are the right side
and the back side
then we go ahead and do the same move
r
u
r prime
u
r
u
u
r prime
and finally u
and now we'll have all four of the edge
pieces of the yellow cross that are
matching
all right now we have a cube where two
layers are completely solved
and when we look at the yellow layer
we have made the white cross
so the next step is to put the corners
in the correct position
so we inspect if any of the corners are
in the correct position
this blue matches the blue but the
orange does not match the red
the green matches the green but the
orange does not match the red
here we have red which doesn't match
orange
and finally
we see that the red and orange so none
of these four corners are in the correct
position your cube may have a few more
but here's what you do you go u
r
u prime
l prime
u
r prime
u prime
and l
so this will bring
at least one of the corners into the
correct position
and here is one of the corners so here
we have green and orange that's in the
correct position
so the remaining corners are not in the
correct position
so we're going to do the same move again
put the correct corner in the upper
right of the face you're looking at
so we go u
r
u prime
l prime
u
r prime
u prime
and l
and this will move the other corners
around
so it doesn't matter whether they're in
the correct orientation for now
we see that all right none of the
corners have actually been moved to the
correct position
so we go ahead and do the move once more
u
r
u prime
l prime
u
r prime
u prime
and l
and now
we actually have put all of the corners
in the correct position
so some of them are not in the correct
orientation that's what we'll solve in
the next video
all right we're almost done we have two
layers of the cube completely solved we
have the yellow cross solved and now all
of the corners are in the correct
position but maybe not the correct
orientation
so there's just one move that we need to
use to put them in the correct
orientation
so looking at any of the faces
we go
r
prime
d prime
r
d
and we look to see if that yellow is at
the top since it's not we do the same
move again we go r prime d prime
rd
and now this yellow is at the top
now what's very important we hold the
cube we look at the same face and we
rotate just the top
now we repeat the same sequence we go r
prime
d prime
r d
yellow is not at the top so we do it
again
r prime
d prime
r
d
yellow is not at the top so we're going
to have to do this two more times
r prime d prime r d
and finally once more r prime
d prime
r
and d
and now when we rotate the cube in the
top layer
we have two of the corners that are in
the correct
position and the correct orientation
and we have two corners that need to be
solved
so we're going to repeat this procedure
we look at one of the faces where the
corner
is not in the correct orientation
and we go
and we're going to solve these two
corners using the same sequence of moves
so we go
r prime d prime
r d
then r prime
d prime
r
d
we still don't see yellow at the top so
we go ahead and do this two more times
and at this point we see yellow at the
top
now once again very importantly
looking at the same green face just turn
the top
and we're going to do the same sequence
of moves r prime
d prime
r d
r prime
d prime r d
and at this point we have the corners in
the correct orientation and we've solved
the cube
there's one more case to consider let's
say you have a cube with
two layers solved you have the yellow
cross
and you have
the corners in the correct position but
three of them
do not have the correct orientation
so we're going to do r prime
d prime
r
d and we keep doing this until we see
yellow at the top so we go r prime d
prime
r
d
we still don't see yellow at the top
so we go ahead and do r prime d prime r
d
r prime d prime r d
and now yellow is correctly positioned
at the top this corner is in the correct
orientation so holding on to that face
we turn just the top and we're going to
do the same sequence of moves over again
so r prime d prime r
d
r prime
d prime
r
d
so we don't see yellow at the top so
we're going to need to do this same
sequence moves two more times r prime d
prime r d
r prime d prime r d
now we see yellow at the top
and we once again just turn the top we
hold the face that we're looking at
and we're going to do the sequence of
moves
a few more times until we get that
corner
in the correct orientation
so it's very important that you do these
moves carefully and slowly i'm going to
do them faster because i know i've been
doing it many times but eventually you
will get yellow at the top
and you rotate the top layer and you
solve the cube
i hope you like this entire series
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory you can
support me on patreon catch me on my
blog mind your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker and you can
get my books listed on my website